let's talk about the nine best foods to
get all your fat soluble vitamins what's
the difference between Fat Cycle
vitamins and water-soluble vitamins
there's a huge difference okay at the
cellular level
fat soluble vitamins penetrate the cell
membrane and they go right into the
nucleus okay they go right into the
nucleus and they connect with receptors
that can activate certain genes whereas
water-soluble vitamins are more like
coenzymes they're kind of like helper
molecules that don't go that far into
the nucleus so these fat soluble
vitamins are very very important vitamin
A D E K1 K2 and there are also other
things that are faciable in like your
vegetables and things
phytonutrients right especially
carotenoids like lutein zeaxanthin which
are essential for your eye and they have
anti-cancer properties
and there's benefits of chlorophyll in
certain plants and so what you need to
know about fat soluble vitamins is that
like dissolves light you need to add
some fat to absorb these fossil
nutrients thus adding olive oil to your
salad to extract phytonutrients
and also when you take the fat cyber
vitamins it's important to maybe either
consume them with a meal or add a little
bit of oil or fat to them to increase
your absorption unfortunately
manufacturing companies to extract these
fat soluble nutrients as well as certain
oils like to make like your salad
dressing out of soy or corn or canola
oil they have to use they don't use fat
they use solvents like hexane for
example so there are certain chemicals
that have properties to help dissolve
and break down and extract these fat
soluble elements now the other really
important thing to know about fat
soluble nutrients in general is this
to absorb those nutrients
they are dependent on bile okay from
your gallbladder now the liver makes
bile and it's stored in the gallbladder
and without bile you cannot absorb these
nutrients so bile is necessary
if you have your gallbladder out if you
have a sluggish gallbladder if you have
problems with your liver let's say you
have a fatty liver or whatever that is
going to diminish the bile and diminish
your absorption of those nutrients and
you may not even know you have a
subclinical deficiency for quite some
time unless you understand all the
different signs and symptoms of those
deficiencies but bile that's made by
your liver okay gets stored in the
gallbladder and then that acts on the
fatty food that you eat to break down
some of the fat to a certain level not
100 just to a certain level kind of
emulsifies the fat
so then your pancreas specifically the
enzyme lipase can come in there
and break down that fat to the level of
where you need it
so you can absorb it into your intestine
if you have problems with the pancreas
and you don't have that enzyme that
could be the other reason why
you're not absorbing these fat soluble
nutrients and one of these symptoms for
a pancreatic problem like even
pancreatitis would be skid marks on in
your toilet bowl okay
and your stool floats so those are two
indications that you're not absorbing
the fat from your food it's a simple way
to identify but also if you have gut
damage okay let's say you have scar
tissue in your lining of your intestine
or you have inflammation you're not
going to be able to absorb the fat
soluble nutrients nearly as well if at
all and so you see a lot of people that
are deficient in these nutrients even
though they're taking them because
there's gut damage deep inside the other
thing you need to know is that these
vitamins both fatsiable and
water-soluble come in complexes they
don't come as one nutrient so anytime
you take one of something and not the
others in the normal complex you can
throw all the balance of these nutrients
and throw out the absorption for example
let's take vitamin E you have Alpha Beta
Delta gamma tocopherols you also have
the same thing with the tocatrinals and
then in that complex you have selenium
so every vitamin complex comes with its
own mineral as well vitamin A helps you
differentiate certain cells so in other
words if you're deficient in vitamin A
you can have cells that form on your eye
that are not part of the eye and on your
skin both externally outside and
internally all the skin on the inside of
your body if you have like rough dry
skin that could be a vitamin A
deficiency because the cells are not
reproducing the cells that should be
there they're reproducing a kind of a
rougher version of that cell vitamin A
is really really important for your
immune system okay especially for
viruses and I think it's not really
known and people don't talk about it but
this is why you know you should not go
on a low-fat diet to help your immune
system you need to go on a higher fat
diet to help your immune system
fertility is dependent on vitamin A A
lot of times people talk about the
toxicity of vitamin A but what about the
deficiency of vitamin A and what that
can produce
for this growing baby because remember
these fat soluble vitamins go right into
the DNA and they affect the genes and
the chromosomes especially for growth
and development of a child but hands
down
retinol is the best form of vitamin A
that's the most bioavailable it gets
absorbed versus the beta-carotene which
you know they also call Vitamin A but
they don't really tell you only a very
tiny bit of beta-carotene gets absorbed
um so you're not going to get your
you're needed and required vitamin A
from beta-carotene so this is why
plant-based beta-carotene well it's good
for certain things but it's definitely
not going to give you the the retinol
the active type of vitamin A that you
really need all right now let's talk
about vitamin D vitamin D is
you know it acts like a hormone more
than a vitamin and it's very similar to
cortisol because it can help you with
inflammation it's involved with the
immune system and it's actually made by
your own skin you can make Vitamin D
from UV radiation from the Sun and
what's interesting people are scared
about too much UV causing skin cancer
but you need UV to make vitamin D which
actually prevents skin cancer
so I I really think it's the um
the burning effect of the sun which
creates the damage so if you're out
there in the Sun and you just don't let
yourself get burnt
it's going to be totally fine because
you're going to get enough vitamin D as
well as other benefits from the Sun like
infrared which helps build up your
melatonin which is a very fascinating
molecule all right bone health immune
Health can help lower your blood
pressure you can increase your mood it's
an anti-inflammatory it gets rid of pain
okay so a very important vitamin
vitamin E very important for
neurological conditions as well as your
muscles if you're deficient in vitamin A
you're going to find that your muscles
are just so weak so they strengthen your
muscle and
also very important in heart okay heart
health both in the heart muscle as well
as in the inside of the arteries that go
to the heart so if there's a deficiency
of vitamin E you're not going to be able
to have that protection against
oxidation things like that the heart
tends to cramp more than it should
because of the relationship between
vitamin E
and helping you carry more oxygen load
in the heart on the top of every
mountain peak that people climb you'll
see uh empty bottles of vitamin E
because it helps them with more oxygen
in higher altitudes all right vitamin K1
clotting if you're deficient vitamin K1
you can have problems even
synthesizing DNA so it goes right down
to the core and then but of course
vitamin K2 vital directing calcium where
it should be going it helps you
transport calcium from the wrong place
to the right place okay
now these fat cyber vitamins help you
absorb certain minerals like vitamin A
helps you absorb iodine vitamin D helps
you absorb calcium by a factor of 20x
that's a lot so all you need is a little
bit of vitamin D to really increase your
calcium if you don't have enough vitamin
D you're not going to absorb too much
calcium and then vitamin K2 like I said
helps transport the calcium so it works
with vitamin D3 and I always recommend
that these come together if you're going
to take them as a supplement now these
Foods I'm going to talk about
um
I want to just tell you you're going to
get these fat cyber vitamins a lot more
if it's pasture-raised grass-fed wild
caught okay because when these animals
are fed grains Okay the vitamin E gets
destroyed and if someone tells you you
can get your vitamin E from grains the
problem is you have to grind the grain
you're not going to eat Just Grains by
themselves you're going to grind the
grain as soon as you expose it to oxygen
and sunlight it's going to be destroyed
shortly after that so grains are not a
good source of vitamin E all right let's
talk about the foods egg yolk okay egg
yolk hands down is like a fat soluble
complex supplement okay you're gonna get
every single fat soluble nutrient you
need including vitamin E number two Cod
Liver okay as well as cow liver oil if
you've never had Cod Liver I suggest you
try it it's actually it's kind of like
it's not that fishy it doesn't taste you
know bad at all but it has a unique
taste I like it but it has a consistency
of like pudding but it's just loaded
with omega-3 fatty acids as well as
these fat soluble vitamins uh
specifically vitamin A and vitamin D and
omega-3 and you can also do the cod
liver oil either as itself
or in a little pearl one of the problems
I do notice when people take it is they
tend to burp more with it so there is a
solution you can get cod liver oil as a
powder okay and it's you don't get the
burping you don't taste anything and
I'll put a link down below for that
information if you want to get it in a
capsule okay now uh fatty fish is
another really good source of these fat
soluble nutrients okay vitamin A D E K1
K2 as well as omega-3 fatty acids all
right number four fish eggs now
you might not like the taste of fish
eggs but you can get them as supplements
but out of all the things that are good
for women who are pregnant
um that want to
help create this amazing baby fish eggs
are at the top of the list as well as
women trying to become more fertile or
men becoming more fertile this will do
it all right number five liver okay and
other organ Meats it has loads of
vitamin A and vitamin D and E and K and
all the other fat soluble nutrients you
don't need much okay but uh
this is should be number one number six
poultry fat I do not recommend consuming
chicken unless it has the skin on it
okay and the fat the amount of fat
soluble nutrients in the skin is
fantastic you have vitamin A d e as well
as K and by the way the chicken thigh
has the most vitamin E which is
interesting
shellfish really good for fat soluble
nutrients as well as the trace minerals
number eight cheese and cream okay
European cheese is the best usually in
America we consume more
pasteurized cheese okay but in Europe
they have a lot of raw cheeses that are
just amazing and cream okay now I'm not
talking about ultra pasteurized I'm
talking about if you could find some raw
cream like I did down the street I found
a farm that has amazing cream and I get
the cream every single week and of
course now we're getting two quarts of
cream every single week for my wife and
myself because I'm finding it so
delicious and it satisfies me so much
I mean we're literally consuming like
I'm consuming like a quart of it a week
by myself and my wife's doing the other
court but it's
great in coffee it's great in Foods it's
also great just to put with um walnuts
or even a little bit of berries with a
little couple drops of stevia amazing
amazing stuff but I'm not going to
recommend consuming that much cream
pasteurized you can put in your your
coffee but
I tell you there's nothing better than
raw cream
all right then we get number nine
grass-fed butter I mean it's loaded with
vitamin A vitamin D E K1 and definitely
K2 now before you go I want to tell you
a little story about myself because um
when I do these videos a lot of times
I'm talking about myself my own health
problems I can relate because I've had
just about every single health problem
that probably you had okay and one of
the problems I had which I think I had
I'm pretty sure was something called
osteomalacia and I want to just tell you
a little bit about it because
osteomalacia
is like rickets which is a vitamin D
deficiency for kids but osteomalacia is
a vitamin D deficiency as an adult that
affects the bones okay now I think I
started developing this in ninth grade
it just wasn't like a rickets but it was
definitely the symptoms of osteomalacia
which would be soft bones okay and also
it can affect your teeth I had really
bad teeth I had to go to the dentist all
the time I craved butter as a child
trying to desperately get these uh these
nutrients but I just did not have a clue
of what was going on
I think it started uh in track in ninth
Parade When I joined the team and I
noticed
my pelvis in my lower back was so in
pain it wouldn't recover no matter what
and I walked with a weird gate and I had
tremendous muscle spasm and that was a
severe vitamin D deficiency but I was
out in the sun a lot right so hang in
there I'm going to tell you where that I
think that came from so I had spine
problems and then as I went into
wrestling and then 10th grade 11th grade
12th grade wrestling
both starving myself trying to get into
a certain weight as well as eating pure
junk food right
and I had a lot of gallbladder issues
how do I know that because I had mostly
right shoulder pain which is totally
gallbladder related and I went to get it
treated so many times by the
chiropractor and it never fully you know
was stabilized that was my gallbladder
problem early on and it just so happens
that that bile that gallbladder is
needed to absorb these fat soluble
vitamins primarily vitamin D
to help with bone health and also
vitamin D is behind immune strength I
can't tell you how many times I would
get a sore throat several times a year I
was constantly getting sick
all the time that was low vitamin D
I also had leg weakness I remember in
Wisconsin walking through the snow and
my legs just so heavy I didn't know what
the heck that was that was a vitamin D
deficiency so as it progressed in
wrestling okay I did really good at the
beginning of the season and of course
terrible at the end of the season I did
end up going to State and what was
fascinating is that here I was
Peak health
went to State I go back home the next
week wrestling my little brother okay my
little brother
who is a lot younger
and
end up fracturing my leg from wrestling
my little brother which is impossible to
do unless you had soft bones
then I go into college and I start
wrestling I think within the first week
I end up fracturing my neck I mean with
not that much force so I I literally had
very soft bones at the time because one
of the symptoms is you fracture bones
easily and the reason I'm telling you
this is just because
the importance of this knowledge of not
just the food but your gallbladder what
foods you should eat what foods you
should stay away from identifying the
early symptoms if I only would have
known what I was missing early on and
what to do about it it would have saved
a lot of years of unnecessary
gallbladder pain that lasted probably
the next I don't know 15 years after
that until I finally figured out what it
was so since we're on the topic of facil
vitamins the next best video for you to
watch would be the one on the
gallbladder I put it right here check it
out